all right let's see what is on the minds
of some in our audience we will go to
the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 starting
today with our caller from the
seven-four-zero area code who's calling
today from 7 4 0 and what's on your mind
today
hi my name is Chris hey Chris I was
actually calling because I noticed that
a independent media right so I watched
your show and then after I'm on like
autoplay it goes to CNN MSNBC so I said
it wasn't interested in those right and
now it goes to Comedy Central and the
great shows you got I mean right yeah
yeah now this is on YouTube people who
don't know you're talking about the
YouTube or suggestions yeah right you to
suggestions but if I go to like my 8 if
I want you to decide like AZ youth
content it's always the same person in
my queue or someone in the same area
right so I was like aren't something
else but Chris it sounds like you're
talking through a critical piece of
paper unfortunately so it's it's a
completely that the connection has
imploded so I'm gonna let you go but
this is an important issue we've been
talking about it this is we look look at
our numbers 95% of the video of the
views that YouTube used to give us by
recommending our videos when people
watch other stuff those are gone
they are now going to corporate media
and when people specifically seek out
our content on YouTube the up next
recommendations are all CNN Fox MSNBC
Seth Meyers Stephen Colbert Trevor Noah
etc etc programs you know with tens of
millions or a hundred million dollar
annual budgets it's crazy we can't do
anything about it but we are we are
doing what we can
that's that's all I can say